welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I'm joined by I think you're going to
win the title for the person that's
traveled the farthest for this podcast
it's that right well that's like you've
just come over from Australia I'm with
Andrew McGregor who is a director of
design and build who are based in
Australia and mate we've been speaking
for a while yeah meet you and I'm
excited for this one so as you know
where I always like to start how how did
Andrew McGregor get into recruitment
yeah look it's a great question and I
think I always ask everyone the same
question but then I ask myself why did I
do in the first place because sometimes
I wonder myself but no no the story goes
for most people that most people fall
into the treatment it was similar for me
but sort of backstory was that I was
actually working in the Tax Office
Believe It or Not for three and a half
years which was an interesting
experience and part of my role was
really boring it was and it wasn't
because part of my role was doing tax
investigations I'll go out to places
where we've suspect something was amiss
and I've done football clubs I've done
some famous clubs in in London and then
just so happened that we got this
recruitment company to investigate and
subsequently you go to their offices and
start to look at you know the people in
the office and generally everyone's
young and they're looking sleek and you
got footballs flying around everywhere
loads of noise and I think to myself
I've been in the tax office for three
and a half years and literally I don't
have an email address I don't have
internet they don't give me a phone and
I honestly felt like my life was wasting
away earlier so as the investigation
were going on the director of the
company said to me why didn't you get
into recruitment and that's what laid
the foundation or delayed the idea so to
speak and then I'm obviously one thing
led to another
did the investigation they turned out to
be dodgy ads but that's another story
for yeah but I couldn't help not think
about it more so then probably another
three months went by and that's when I
started to look at four critical
actually proactively that yeah I didn't
it was I spoke to a couple of friends
and friends said don't do recruitment
you won't be any good if you need to
ever sales background but no I got into
it by seeing it probably in the flesh
hmm I'm thinking to myself to know what
I've always been a people's person and
people you know
describe what's the people's person dubs
in military I went to boarding school I
moved every 18 that stuff there I had
that that is tough it isn't but you put
yourself out this whenever you go to a
new military boy
you're always assimilate into people's
culture mmm so for me that meant when I
see Matlock Ruben I was like well I can
do that easily yeah that's really true
that's the story how I got into
recruitment basically investigating
another company in turn now thinking
that looks good for me I wanted some
Rolexes so then let's frame up a bit
then and then we'll sort of dive into
your story so you worked for was it so
you worked for was it much tech you work
for yeah yeah that's right okay and then
how long did you work there for I'm so I
spent four years there okay and now is
your first yeah that was my first
recruitment subway there for four years
and then after that you then and then is
that when you left to go to Australia
yeah that's right yes I spent four years
there when it started as a junior
consultant as you didn't progressed over
the time it's a team lead role but then
after about four years started to come a
little bit over some of the mentality of
a big corporate if you wanna come will
dive into that and then after that you
then when so trade did you start your
own business straight away or did you
then obviously work for someone from no
so I originally joined designer billed
as a consultant oh yeah in Melbourne so
I basically Neal was advertising the
magazine for recruitment consultants and
I got in touch yeah join as a consultant
what was that now almost nine years ago
okay so then and then you've obviously
got to the point where you are now they
design and build over the nine years
yeah yeah that's right okay cool so
you've lived in Australia for how long
come nine years all right cool so let
excited to unpack that then so go into
much tech obviously yeah what were they
like obviously big at that point when
you joined
yeah I think they were approximately 200
250 people RK and it was a single size
office at the time so when you walked in
it was it was a suit tie yeah and what
was the sector that you went into I went
into civil engineering highlights in
effect yeah but yeah it was that that
interview experience was I've never
experienced anything like it I never
will again talk some four stages yeah
every stage they're telling you you're
not good enough job
against other people's a lot Groupon was
a dish year no no it's just me okay
and like each interview is about an hour
and you know no you're not good you
can't eat it she never themselves you'd
agree I'm sat there I don't have I can
swear can I sell yeah [ __ ] you make
because I'm one of those don't tell me I
can't do something but there's even a
psychrometric there was an intelligence
test yeah and then you had to meet the
MD and I got for all of that my first
day you didn't meet the MD on the first
week and he sat then he said I don't
know what you're doing you how you doing
mmm-hmm yeah you don't have the
convention of that I'm not sure but
we'll see how you go I lasted longer
than him okay okay so and super noon and
then just just to help me and understand
and the people listening and then was it
contract Lee went into was it perm yes
we've been contracting with in local
councils and Highway Authority so an
example be the Highways Agency or
Transport for London so all I did was
highways and matchstick were very
specialist so it wasn't if it was a bus
stop or a bus route or a traffic a cycle
wait I can touch it had to be someone
designing the road or supervising the
construction of a road inspecting a road
but it it effectively made me that five
Marcy yes I made you super nice but it
allowed you just to go straight to the
home and say this is who I'm this is
what I do all I do is watch yeah and
they were very smart about okay amazing
so let's well I always like to ask
people before we move on how are you
first time Monson so you had to send the
send Andrew nanny not sure we'll see how
it goes
how were the first time months I was
rubbish really no look first the first
three months for me I started late
October so I still remember my first
placement that came in sort of early
January I'm a didn't you always remember
your first day I remember my first free
I think but really I think the second
guy stood in the jello me to tell you it
took about so I started 26th of October
and I think the first deal was early
January like 34 January so took a bit of
time hence the reason why they give me a
bit of stick but I did the numbers yeah
but look it was difficult because I
hadn't come from ourselves background
yeah and you know they hammered you but
at the same time what I remember about
it was that sort of every call got
better mmm every phone call just got a
bit easier and a bit easier something
after six to nine or six to seven months
you've spoken to these people at least
eight times yeah so start to know who
you are you starting to consistently
talk to them and suddenly you feel like
it's a switch you're like oh yeah that
conversation just worked a lot better
yeah then the other six had gone and
that's sort of when and it started
really build after about seven to eight
months that's when tempers went from one
to ten to twenty and I think you know it
went on from there and really harm but
the I always say to people you know six
to nine months it's always difficult mmm
I put on would you go back and do
anything differently um you know it's
funny somebody else asked me that and
it's so so long ago yeah that I look at
it and go well I can't change the past
because I could do differently probably
not I probably could it would have been
easier and I think today's world because
they've got we've got podcasts yeah
because we've got books etc else I
always say to people if you want to make
it easier listen to these you don't get
a lot of help in the first and you
always looking for people to sort of
help you so I always said anyone if you
want to make it easier you know what
listen to these podcasts because we've
all been there yeah and I know I think
again that sort of what this was born
out of really I worked for a small
boutique agency and I learned so much
from everyone around me but like I just
totally recognized that I could there's
got to be so many more people out there
that I can learn from
okay just quickly then before we move on
I guess what how did you how cause I'm
just thinking people listening who are
maybe going for that period at the
moment six eight months in their first
12 months where it is still really
difficult hmm and did you just naturally
when you get off these calls and you're
improving what do you say okay what
could have improved there or did you
give I mean like how what was the
process of you getting better was you
asking for help would you listen to
other people or would you getting off
the phone was going right hand really
that's that's gone really well why was
that how could I improve that then
really what did you give I mean yeah
look I think one of the things I was
taught very early on
give me wrong match that were great at
the train yeah you know what I was
taught and what I always say to everyone
is make sure you get something from
every call and then it could be
something that's quite and significant
but just look to get something from
every call and it could be so
insignificant as when'd you next want to
talk when's the next time I can speak to
you because whilst that might not sound
significant when you call them back you
turn around say you told me to call you
on this day so therefore you've had a
win along the way but what I've always
said in every today and you know 9:13
plenty years ago I never Krugman is you
know when [ __ ] goes wrong that's fine
what did I learn and what am I gonna do
next time yeah so there's always that
sort of you know analyze every call but
don't overanalyze it just get on the
phone get beat up a little bit because
you're gonna get beyond of course yeah
prioritize speaking to a lot of
candidates you know when if you've been
set a target of you know whatever 100
calls 150 whatever it is double that
with candidates because they'll be the
ones that will give you the information
they'll they'll build your confidence
yeah but you know I also immerse myself
in ministry I learn about every project
really I learn about you know every
company and how many tips they've got
what's the maximum never had a good
memory because I did a course yesterday
with a contractor and he had a really
good memory as well and I had like I
don't know what it is but an example
would be that um consultant Charlotte
was actually back in UK now she and she
was talking to this chap and she shouted
across the desk to another guy she said
I'll just [ __ ] just Peter Phillips I
went oh yeah he worked for that company
in Brisbane in this role back in about
2012 England she looked to me like I had
four heads
she went natural comes naturally to man
I still remember my clients numbers so
when I got back I called a couple of
them just because I remember their
number it's it's just some people have
got that yeah in their brain yeah and I
always say that you know and don't want
to be rude to people but you you
generally want to test people's memories
and try and figure out how much they
remember because that's what people buy
into when you want to build trust with
someone you refer battery and I can give
you a bit of point of difference and
they stand out yeah when you walk into a
client's office you know a candidate and
they talk about a company or something
you just got all that person that person
does it they look at you like all right
all right so you're serious it's like
yeah I like that cause then just um I
know you touched on a bit help me
understand so you obviously billing that
went well then you went the what and
then did you go up the traditional ranks
of matched excellent yeah that's right
you said what did you what did you vote
to so my first role was junior
consulting yeah then you move into
consultant and then senior but I always
had aspirations for leadership money you
always thought about yeah well my
father's a leader in the military so
therefore he started as you know a
gunner which effectively is the bottom
run rank and I watched him progressing
so senior roles in the military so I saw
some examples of him being a leader and
I think it was inspired just stuck with
me and so you know I always wanted that
leadership role so I moved into a team
lead role after about two to three years
yes before you laugh yeah I did yes I
ran a team for about a year and actually
going back to one of those biggest
regrets was my first year management I
was a complete nob
yeah but I'd learned from other managers
in the business who were bit [ __ ]
like yeah but my last year I pulled my
head back in but yeah the last year was
leading a team of four to six
consultants recruiting the sort of
highway space really okay let's just
unpack that a bit and then we'll dive
into the Australian stuff which I'm
really keen today hmm
okay so then firstly like
performance-wise did you just get was it
did you get that management position the
leadership role because he was
performing really well a lot right
Andrey if you can create three four five
more handers then this can be really
profitable yeah I think that was the
model of matchstick really sort of um
once you get to a certain point in your
billion you get put into more of a
senior role you know I think they
promote bad people in the promote good
people like any business does but you
know I got up to sort of over 100 temps
out really I was building what does that
mean villain was roughly it was probably
about 15 to 20 grand a week really
roughly up to 500 600 K a year is that
like your best biggest years yeah really
yes so but it's the match tape model you
know incredibly well and you didn't hear
attempts from people left in order
jazz but the issue they always had was
it was marching it was love timesheet
marketing but you know that's what where
I was successful was you know I got into
an account and never assumed that I knew
everyone in the account because I think
a lot of recruiters they get too
comfortable
but I was like okay so that's that
division I've got four temps there but
over there
Anders have got six temps so I need to
go and get their tips got four over
there and he didn't ban I got four there
so I was always right where else can I
be a cool just yeah just quickly then
thinking again how people can get value
listening let's I think there'll
probably be a lot of people listening
the contract recruiters they might have
hit a bit of a glass ceiling or they're
more at their know in there as to like
where you got to you but have
aspirations to get there I guess yeah
you can also talk about your experience
in Australia as well but I guess looking
back what do you think were the key
things that enable you to get to that
sort of 500 600 K plus or the amount
attempt suit you've got to you mentioned
just a bit of a and a valuable piece
there but what were the sort of key
things would you say that enable you to
get to that to that point I think you
know some people just got habits where
it's never enough and for me every time
I hit a certain milestone whether or not
my five grand that we can contract six
grand a week seven grand a week eight
grand what's next
but where is it as well because you've
got to be smart about the clients that
you're trying to target there's no point
in talking to clients where you know if
you're a contract recruiter and they've
they've only had never had one temp well
you know what there's not opportunity
that you need to be identifying clients
where they're a project based client and
they have seasonal you know projects
whatever else and suddenly you know at
their peak they've got 12 and right now
they've got one how'd you find that out
then asking information you know
speaking to temps you know continue just
to always mine for information yeah and
it sort of it's a it's an interesting oh
so how many times you got the mount one
that's not many year but when we're
really busy when they're busy we've got
12 so you always want to be mindful of
you know there's one client was six
temps but they've only ever at six and
they're with one agency your opportunity
successes list and we've got for now but
when we've had 12 oh how many of you had
them with about eleven agencies isn't
that difficult for you to manage of
eleven different agencies you always
took mining for solutions and
information and that's how I did it was
always right that's Mike attempts there
but where
elsewhere elsewhere else the new DAST
attempts and then you look after your
temps as well I mean one of the things
max that did really well he couldn't not
speak two attempts every four weeks
because they were on you just like a
brick about it about actually yes then
in touch so you know you'd spend time
and you take them out for beers you'd
get to know these people because they're
human beings right you know it's their
job and they you know most of them you
know they work in Tempe they want to
know that you look after them you
looking out for them and the moment you
do that they'll look out for you and
accept or ask you know they know they
are there to make money it's just how
you make it you do make it really well
would you just make it by being selfish
and for me it was always like right go
to London every week spend time in
attempts and then the other temps who
didn't work free match tech would be
like why can't I go out for beers and
why are my home looked after and the
best example for me was two years ago
when I got married my best man was my
temp well my ex just heart now it makes
contract really in Australia meaning to
know each other in London we got but you
get to build friendships of these people
yeah yeah and so he was my temp for two
years I left and then someone gave me a
reference to do about four years later
and it was strewn and called him up and
I was like hello you little wanker for
God's sake I got away from you know
subsequently we put up a friendship and
okay so to run that off then I think
what you said there was which is really
interesting was from a contract
recruited right now have you actually
made it time to think about the accounts
that you're working in the account so
you've identified are they accounts that
people really busy times are gonna need
a lot more of a service for you need
more people and have a real think about
that and if if it isn't a case then
start trying to find out who who are the
people that and who are the businesses
that need a lot of people in these times
the other thing which I've heard before
obviously is really really double down
on in kind of that network that is yes
getting to know them more than it needs
to be more than transaction Brian and
because if you've got a really good
relationship then hopefully lots of
thing that if they get a call by another
recruit it's often them ten fifteen
twenty could more per hour whatever
you'd like something well actually
Andrews really looking after did you go
I mean I guess that's the sort of object
there isn't it so would that be fair so
those are all key things that enabled
you to really excel to at that point I
think there's two other things also is
you know what do your clients do are
they all capital expenditure late or are
they operational expenditure
as well okay it's having a balance of
clients about what sort of projects and
what sort of work that they do
mmm because if you're just all your
clients are capital expenditure that
they're alive is our answer so their
money coming into this is investment
okay they're working on projects that
needs to be built or their new projects
yeah whereas operation was sort of
existed in churn projects so like I said
grading so you'd always want the balance
of what your clients - yeah this is
really learning that an exactly I think
I'm it's funny when you much about
Canada networks my um nickname was
payroll King really that's it because
literally people would call me but I've
just got from Australia I've got a job
with this company and I've been told to
call you I mean yeah that's the nickname
I got because I just looked after the
people yeah that's amazing so okay cool
and then and just be interesting to get
your thoughts cuz again thinking the
people listening a lot of people which
I'm sure you've experienced it now and
in your time in Australia but obviously
that is still quite common where a
really good billow is then pushed into
management even maybe if they do want it
or don't want it so I guess you did say
though that obviously when when you
started when you did start that
management career you was a bit of an
Abed so let's unpack that and quickly
sort of talk a bit about the learnings
that you experienced you that because
I'm sure there's a lot of people that
maybe I'll but currently a bit of a know
better than these things we're trying to
try and understand how to manage people
and how not to manage people so what did
you learn for that period then and one
of the things that you definitely would
be different you know I mean yeah look I
did do them differently
yeah um because I think people want to
be inspired and motivated to be better
than himself whereas when you're a
younger manager and you're trying to
bully them to be new it was that that
that's quite common ease news like what
I do in do you know it were you know it
works it's like why would you not do
that that's what I but it only works for
you exactly yeah you know one thing you
learn is that what works for you and he
works for you and you only
yeah you can try and work to people to
build their own habits and ways but you
are you you are unique so don't believe
people into submission don't create a
culture where it field people coming to
work thanks inspire people making
recruitment yeah that's what I learned
you know I tried to replicate what my
manager had done but actually I you know
with respect him I didn't really like
him because the way it treated me yeah
and then you know I remember getting
home one day and a few of my mates and I
probably acted out you know with my
mates and they were like stop being a
[ __ ]
yeah and then I saw myself I'm like that
at work so what must they think about me
how do i how can I help them do better
and it was like well stop doing what
you're doing right now you know have you
know open conversations and motivating
Susan Rice at Chen it is a mindset
change you know but it took a little
while but fortunately for me sort of up
towards the end there you know we had a
team of people where we were all in it
together yeah because what I learned
when I went to Sydney enough so you not
to get too far ahead but I wouldn't be
where I was today without my team yeah
course so you know I was glad that I
learned that early on because if I
wasn't not being a completely different
job and it completely some country
somewhere else in the world yeah so it
really was that mindset change of I
guess been less selfish basically yeah
yes about you more about them yeah and
that as simple as that that would be
your advice to people that are going
through that transition at the moment
yeah yeah and it will pay a dividend as
long time they will yeah if you if you
give people time and you know and
obviously there's always another part to
management and management of people but
you know given time to get to where they
need to get to just give them the
guidance and the motivation don't
believe I thought you'd have the payroll
King name I remember one of the ladies
who work for me in Sydney issue it to me
oh yeah I remember you know payroll cool
mate so Australia them yeah really
really keen to dive into this then so
firstly like how did that happen so it
was it literally you saw a magazine
advert in a magazine yes oh wait wait
for it sister this is actually a funny
story it's originally a contact of
rhetoric and he got me in touch with
these free absolute basket cake
companies and I was like right I'm
finishing this look yeah straightaway
but then I read the new civil engineer
magazine which is obviously a magazine
for engineers about projects in the UK
and Neil the director of design and
build had advertised for recruitment
consultants in in Australia and I
thought well hold on a minute this is
pretty smart I'm reading a magazine
about projects and it says Australia
infrastructure boom recruitment can
start require design and build and hours
I love the dick and balls logo back in
the day
you know we'll talk about later but I
like that straight away you know it was
difficult that smart yeah and so I
emailed Neil I said look you know I've
been thinking about it for a while I'd
actually add 25 finishers that day as
well so I was instead advised I'm better
I emailed Neil I said let me know this
is who I am this is what I've done and
the him and I spoke for 20 minutes in
the phone on a Sunday and that's about
two days later and then I spoke to Matt
they have a director for about two about
an hour and then I was in Australia
fibers later really yeah no skypes no
face times no CV at the time just two
conversations and then what was the
biggest driver behind that then for me
yeah I'm just emerging as a you know
I've done psychometrics and I've got a
high agency okay and I was just like
right if I'm gonna do it just do it now
so just why did you want to go over
there the idea of it really 26 at the
time 2027 at a time and I thought to
myself you never you know you put
yourself out there by leaving it a safe
job and got into recruitment if you're
gonna leave you know match take do you
want to compete against them would you
try something completely different I was
like well Australia sounds good I've
never been to Australia really um so
yeah just silly she had never been there
before no love that then wives in
Melbourne it's free degrees pissing down
rain
so yes away it's a where-where'd was
initially based in based in Melbourne
for 18 months okay and then where do you
live now I live in Sydney it's in there
yeah cool yeah so I guess the first
thing that I'd love to dive in to you
before we go into sort of that that
whole journey would be free that whole
experience now firstly so I'm under the
impression that it was a lot easier as a
UK recruit to go over there as it
compared to as it is now is that is that
correct and saying that oh I don't know
I'll find it surprising that people say
it's easier in Australia I just think I
don't know isn't easy to get over there
I'll show you a lot more about you yeah
yes that's what I meant sorry other visa
yeah this or vehicle you see oh it was
it is that fair to say because you know
how it is if you're a recruit right now
you're listening you've got two years
three years four years experience again
you getting nailed by rhetorics right
we're gonna say there's opportunities
Australia it seems like everyone centres
opportunities in America now on these
things so like yeah what's the actual
reality of a UK recruiter right now
being able to go over to Australia just
the opportunities are still there yeah
right but you see you can't is achieve
yes so I put on LinkedIn the other day
it's two years experience and a relevant
degree but a relevant degree is business
management HR right not psychology law I
was relevant to the craft or it's five
years experience to get a visa about a
degree but if your five-year agreement
yeah but if you're you know that's
that's what they state now don't get me
wrong some people are able to get visas
outside of that I never know how yeah
but what you know if you were in your
20s you know you've got four years you
can go to Australia spend three six
months traveling around and then go and
work for a company for six months and
you're working holiday and then you've
got the five years and then there would
that be easier that that would be easy
just to get out there and get a feel for
Australia actually that's probably a
better smile right so because the cost
to Australian businesses of hiring
through the visa process has almost
tripled in the last everyone's sort of
five years so you know the the risk to
Australian businesses of hiring people
from the UK has just gone up
exponentially along with the the
significant salaries that we have to buy
now yeah okay cool so it's definitely
still achievable absolutely and I think
you just gave some good advice in terms
of maybe a slightly different way to
approach it yeah and okay and then the
other thing that just to get your
perspective of and then we'll talk about
in Australia is and what should UK
recruited be thinking about before they
go over to Australia to like move their
life there or career there through your
whole nine years there now like what the
hell should these people be thinking
about if they're seriously considering
moving abroad with their recruitments
go-set yeah it's it's actually a great
question you know I think there's a
realization that when you first move to
a new country your first three to six
months are getting to know people right
and I talk about working I'm talk about
personal yeah so if you are in the
position where you can get a working
holiday yeah I would recommend getting
there and going to Australia
getting settled getting to know people
getting networks of people here before
you take a job mmm because once you get
into the job you've got to commit to the
job yes you know because when you first
get out to Australia you say yes to
everything you know yes to doing
everything problem isn't work takes
secondary to that yeah as sunny you find
yourself six to nine months into the
role and you haven't you know you
haven't focused enough on it should be
doing your personal stuff
I think to myself that's the one thing
first get out there and get to know
people to travel with some social
networks it's not as you light on the
other side of the world from yeah
immerse yourself in Australian culture
don't go do that just go to football go
to the beach going to Ozzy say is that
like actual football that was easy
football I love Ozzy rule really never
works yeah I went to the game early on
with Aziz right but what you find
sometimes is people just spend their
time in English groups or Scottish
groups or Irish groups and then they
start to say to themselves you know I'm
not really enjoying Australia I'm not
and it's because they're not doing the
Australian life which is getting
outdoors and because in basically in the
UK you sit indoors and wait for it to
stop raining in Australia you're outside
and you're waiting for it to rain
because it's you bloody up so I think
immerse yourself in the Australian
culture if you're gonna and you've
already got a job make sure you spend
some time learning about the lingo learn
about the locations at the geography
because Oh UK we don't mind travel an
hour and a half year no worries in
Australia they don't like travel in 15
minutes why and it's a big country
travel it's not they would prefer to
spend more time at home yeah in the
morning and more time at home in the
evening they've been traveling so we're
not talking about construction but you
know he said someone hey it's a half an
hour drive look you've got four hits
block really I know it's not good I want
to be within 20 30 minutes at home
that's extreme but that's how
Australians thinkers I want to spend
less time at work more time at home and
I'm not gonna compromise to home park
really I'm some new mates of the
Australian market yeah cool all right
interesting hmm
so nine years and you've only worked for
design and build that's right yes so two
jobs in 13 years of equipment god help
me I'm lucky number 13
yeah so then okay just just to give me
some context into frame art then so and
join them as what sort of level cuz of
so you had quite a bit of now just--can
i am i took a consultant rod you know my
view I wasn't a team leader I wasn't a
scenic in song so I knew nothing
different market yeah and would you go
into the same sort of Kneeshaw I went
from civil engineer and contract to
construction permanent oh really oh yeah
what's the plan recruitment which was my
I remember doing my first job advert and
I was like what how do I do this really
it's like you've never done a job I went
made up a temp worker
yeah okay so just give me the context so
it was a consultant consultant for how
long
permit firm consultant in the Melbourne
office for 18 months yeah recording a
construction and then we had started up
a Sydney office you know whilst I was in
Melbourne had been going for about two
years had been going very well
you know wrong people wrong direction
whatever else and I was a little bit
despondent with Dean B at the time you
know what liar
I thought the business was potentially
going backwards in some of the things it
was doing yeah so I put my hand up and
said hey can I go to Sydney and try and
help you you know get the office go in
the right direction and trying to put my
own sort of stamp on it in a way and
obviously I had that leadership
aspirations so I moved to Sydney
seven seven years ago I mean I stayed
there since yet and when you joined
there was what usually when straightens
a lot of leadership role took estate
manager role at the time as myself
and there's for others when I'm when I'm
in three of them went because you know
new leader etc else so I was lucky that
we got Kelly's you know myself Natalie
brought on Kelly in May joined in April
yeah and then Alex who and Kelly and
Alex are still with us today
and then how many people in listening
office 24 oh wow yeah okay and you've
sort of led the direction of that and
yeah obviously other people yeah you
know we wouldn't be where we were
without there - yeah Alex and Kelly and
the other leaders that have come through
mmm but yeah you know during that time
we've had a great uptick in consultants
and gone for a bit of turnover as well
okay and then was you and then did you
stay in that perm yeah I stay in that
market I stayed billing as a building
consultant in construction permanent for
another five years old oh really
yes building up until about 18 - about
two years ago really okay cool let's
unpack that then and then I'd love to
sort of get your perspective of and sort
of how you can recruiters have done when
moving out of Australian some of the
biggest pitfalls or the common thing
that you've seen these people and these
things but yeah let's just unpack that a
bit and so how was that whole transition
for you then like was that a difficult
period that at the start yeah it was ya
know it wasn't easy going from you know
being very confident a rocking payroll
King it was like that you like top dog
to lights yes I was you know
in a plaque in a pile of [ __ ] the
maggots at the bottom would be at the
top yeah I was at the top yeah and then
I became a maggot and you know I
remember the first phone calls even the
first phone call all right mate
and he was like yeah all right how are
you cuz I didn't say how you going again
how you going that's how you should that
was that was my first phone call he said
I said oh you're right and he was like
yeah I'm fine why you ask him you know
just suddenly speaking the lingo so the
next one goes like the guy was like yeah
right you're right in all seriousness
you know is getting to learn permanent
recruitment but I always will say hand
on heart I always believed ten
recruiters a bit recruiters because the
amount of plates you spin in just the
amount of volume and the energy that you
bring into the desk and permanent can be
quite slow so I think in a great permit
or some that creates urgency great
energy it's already there in permanent
is not so you gonna iterate it so that's
what I live in so how did how did you
how did you deal with that transition
then like what did you do what the
different things that you had to change
and like the different like did you have
a different approach and yeah it's that
they didn't need someone yes yesterday
they sort of wanted to bring somebody on
board so yet to suddenly learn about
crafting you know how you would talk
about candidate skills and experience
and what value they could add to the
business because previously was I need a
design engineer for three months who's
got MX right okay I'll go and find
someone who's got em extreme spots
bashed around whereas there's obviously
gotta be decent but still it's very
relying on the school so they have that
perfect you know networks you knew who
was good and then they said well I want
and they always give you the hard roles
first remember in any new business role
you're doing they won't give you the
easy stuff I mean me the hardest roles
and so you'd be like right and then you
have to talk to Kyle about what Maori
they're gonna add so that your sell of
Canada it's completely changed and then
you've got to learn more about you can
that exasperation sighs so that was what
I found was okay wasn't just I have a
job here for this long do you want it
yes you do great go it was well I have
an opportunity that I want to talk to
you about but before we get into that I
want to learn about what are the things
that are gonna make you want to leave I
can imagine that be insightful check
yeah oh oh my days and then you're
negotiating fee
was different because then you're
talking about the value you're adding to
the client and what they were paying for
was in temp they're paying for the need
yeah I need someone that's what I'm
gonna get
whereas in when your relocation in terms
of business with clients in permanent
it's about what value you're adding what
features and benefits of your terms yeah
I'm so there's all these different
things coming into it but what I did I
just create urgency and I had a lot
going on right if I'm gonna I went with
the rule of three back then which was
you know for every three interviews I'll
get one placement yeah so if I won
twelve and a quarter or one a week and a
quarter I need to at least have face its
unique candidates our interview only one
time so it's just always about the
volume I'm don't get me wrong some I
think one core worry about 80-inch
fusing about two placements but that's
because I was a very good know so for me
I just took the temp approach which was
always make sure you've got three to
five new things on but box each one off
and move on
I'm so I think that's the mentality of
always had and I think Tim recruits
that's why they generally have the high
level success yeah cool okay and then
just quickly then if I'm the contractor
now and I've taken on position into poem
what the things that I need to be like
right I need to get this sword or
whatever she said about great that have
that same urgency these things
understand that actually how are your
position in your candidates and how you
understand them is different these
things but just to wrap that piece up
then if I'm a pawn recruiter right now
going for that transition what are you
telling me to try and make sure that
I'll get back to this officer you
summarize what you said earlier was is
that you've got to learn your candidates
as an aspiration yeah you've also got to
learn your clients and you you're asking
different questions to your clients
about permanent recruitment wealth and
contract so you've already summarized
summarize it quite nicely okay I think
the other thing is also negotiating a
stand-your-ground in the terms business
yeah I'm that pretty pants down no and
but understand why not so I but because
clients think they're paying for the
outcome and a guarantee knowing that's
what they negotiate terms a business on
there how much your fee is yeah what
your payment terms are yeah and what
your guarantee is yeah right that's not
what that's not what a painful mmm
they're paying for all the stuff you do
before that so it's about educating your
clients about that part of the process
that's what you need to learn because
you know I talk to the consultants and
other sort of peers a lot about features
and benefits clients call us because of
two reasons because they want the time
with the money that's what they could
ever got the resource himself to do it
and
the money to do either but they don't
call you because they think you're gonna
waste your time or their time and they
think you're gonna cost you much money
so you sort of got overcome these two
things that can afflict against each
other and I think that any great poem
accrue that's what they learn yeah I
know how to negotiate your position so
that you win exclusive business and you
win it for the right reasons which isn't
because of the fee or the guarantee is
because of the service you provide mmm I
mean that's something I learned over
that sort of four to five years in
permanent acrimony which is why in the
last three years all I did was retained
mmm really yeah okay cool we're
different talk about that so just
quickly and this this part of the
business also know it's been going for
copiers beforehand but like was it
pretty much you building up from scratch
pretty much yeah so designing bills been
established was 15 years of this yeah
yeah but the Sydney branch had opened up
in 2010 in mid mid 2010 I went there mid
2012 okay I'm so long with Kelly nasty
and Alex it was the forest and for 18
months believe you me mate it was really
[ __ ] I hit rock bottom personally hit it
professionally you know I was I was in a
bad way
what about that just making silly
mistakes as a 29 year old really sort of
single man and Sydney does and I made
some poor decisions personally which
obviously knock-on effects you
professionally yeah but what kept us as
a team was our to giving us every
success we had we celebrated it could
even be a good conversation with a
client the moment it happened because we
were in a room and offices people can't
see this but this rooms probably four by
three yeah four by four maybe yeah maybe
this is the size of our room that we're
in right so you'd hear every call good
or bad and we need a good call or a good
job on or a good interview candidate you
like mate [ __ ] well done yeah the
potential that could be because we you
know as recruiters were always about the
opportunity and what it could mean and
be um so that's what we did for you is
pretty much building they're pretty much
grown out of you guys yeah okay we had a
strong brand though as well me design
and build that people recognized it for
what okay the reason why I'm asking you
about that is they're probably the most
common question I get asked to ask
guests on the show it is around building
a desk and business development and
these things and so I guess I'd love to
just get your perspective of how you
approached building that business
obviously wasn't just you but you guys
as a collective what this sort of
key things that you did to get to the
point where you are now in terms of the
sort of busy building the clients and
building yeah that part of the business
I mean it's an yeah it does we'll look I
think firstly and foremost um every new
recruits are every experienced recruiter
when they come to Australia go to UK us
they look at the biggest companies the
best companies in markets they are one
of a crew for that company that's the
first mistake they make really because
they don't need you right
why don't they need them because they've
got everyone else yeah what else is
chasing in the service right you have to
work with companies who need you so
where are the other people in it so you
got your sort of tier one you if you
talk about either Microsoft Google we've
talked about construction then least
multiplex yeah yeah subjects our
listeners don't try and recruit for them
in the year one okay build up to them in
year five you start with your SEO down
in the air don't start with the big boys
because people assume that a company of
20 doesn't need to recruit via recruiter
well if their turnover twenty percent
that's four hires a year yeah right if
you can then take on two of those hires
they all you need is probably in the
first year this is where it's not you
know years two three and four but you
probably only need another ten clients
and there's 20 hires in a year and
there's 300 grand and billions mmm
rather than trying to recruit for
Lindley co-op let's get one role in that
whole year be competing against all
these other critical companies and
internal solutions barking mad so after
s amis where there's teams of 20 40 60
what did you map them out yeah you're
talking to line managers you're talking
to decision by law right and you're
establishing again you know how much
recruitment do you do you know how many
people you leave in the last year what
should turnover you get company say I've
got 60 people on my turnovers 40 you're
like right so twenty four times a year
you've got to go and find someone yeah
right okay well hold on how much in
terms of recruitment generally we
probably hire six to eight people in a
year for recruits how many different
recruiters six bingo you're in good spot
that's what you've got to do start to
talk to your recipes first build your
brand build your networks deliver on
knows and then what what happened over
time is you'll start to make your way up
into the mid tier space and then say
Billy network you mean the client
delivery I'm working for deliver deliver
deliver because you can also make
mistakes as well in that in that in
detail there's enough of it yeah then so
what what you did we started one desk I
got that desart moved off it brought
somebody in another des
proce they're just set up and then move
away from it move away from it to give
it to somebody else and now we do
recruit from the top companies in trade
with you start with you so that would be
your advice then yeah and never forget
them either because there will still be
80% of your business
will come from this Emmys mmm because
you're still didn't you know talk about
gatekeepers and stuff like that there
are no gatekeepers in this yeah you are
dealing with this how you approaching
these people like real practical I was
like the go-to to me is just phones
business always have been but you know I
always sort of go with the track of okay
let's look at a project they've won and
then give them a call about that so have
something so that's sort of you know you
can use sort of project trackers except
or else and you know introductory call
also this is who I am this is what I do
I understand you've won this project and
go that sort of conversation but you
know there's obviously the the marketing
you can do behind it in terms of brand
yeah yeah but I'm always fine first
people want to still deal with people
right yeah I'm definitely all about the
fine it's just what can you do online
like the department you said about the
projects that's an online element and
what what else can you do that can help
that phone and call conversation and
what else can you do online to breed
trust and credibility before you pick up
that phone yeah I think in today's
society in terms of what we've got in
terms of link to you and sort of other
sort of social sites and websites you
can be looking at that information that
companies providing about who they are
what they stand for you know you start
seeing them take part in sort of charity
accept or else you start seeing take
part in sort of industry events start to
talk about because when you speak to
some of the first time they want to know
if you're serious or not yeah and if
you're just gonna in cold
you're gonna have your pants pulled down
pretty quickly here was if you're gonna
move something which is I understand you
take part in this all rounds think
you've got to take part and that have
something to talk about has talked about
okay and then and so how so then I'll
see you continues billion for quite a
while then how did that go billions did
that they did do that obviously through
that you had a tough period but it was
fine I mean always make my budget in
fact that one quarter I didn't build a
thing which was a bit of a squeaky palm
moment really but for me it was always
about getting to budget but it was never
about being the biggest pillar hmm for
me it was about getting something Sarah
and then getting the [ __ ] out the way
and get something else it and building
something that was bigger than myself
that because that was what was more
important to me wasn't having a team of
four where we were all
bill and [ __ ] loads of money okay well I
want to create an opportunity for Kelly
to leave eventually people eventually
that's what she wants yeah same for Alex
so I can only do that by building
something that's bigger than us so was
never about being the biggest biller it
was about building something bigger than
me okay
just quickly before I dive in this
asking you about it because you
mentioned it how did you get you
touching it but like how did you get
through those real tough times I made my
personal professional you know I mean
because yeah there must be more to it
then I totally get that you're in a room
like we are today it's four of you
against the world like you'll celebrate
everything that you achieved together
totally get that because it's not just
about Andrew then an analyst problem is
there's actually other people that are
on with me on this journey how cause I
can imagine if I'm if I move over to
Australia on a recruiter listening and
I'm over there at the moment maybe and
it is [ __ ] difficult and it's really
tough like what what how did you get
through that real tough time then seek
help really yeah just ask for help you
know I am perspectives one thing right
and we could talk about that later but
seeking help is you know I'm struggling
you know I'm not finding this easy I'm
having you know personal professional
problems be willing to just up and say
no I don't suck it up and see that you
know you've got to seek help and yeah
seeking help have to be embarrassed by
it but yeah how helped me because I you
know I need at the moment and then
people start to talk to you about their
problems hmm and you go how did you get
over that I talk to people about it I've
sought help so I think whenever you have
in those moments where you like [ __ ]
this is this is really [ __ ] rather than
go into it into a shell yeah go and
speak to people it could be your family
it could be afraid it doesn't have to be
recruiters yeah it can be anyone right
because we've all been there we've all
had moments where we've been at work or
at home on a football pitch on a bloody
guess that that's where it can be really
tough if you move to the other side of
the world and you feel like you've got
no one to ask help from do you have
everyone else who's moved across had the
same issue there's always those people
out there have been in the same boat as
you
yeah you know you're not alone you never
are there's always people in it have
moved to a new country and they've gone
through the same trials and tribulations
and so what I tell people a lot and when
I mentioned about going to Australia was
say and it was Kelly that taught me it
should say yes to everything really and
everyone says you want to do yeah
because what you do you quickly find out
what you like and don't like but if you
say no to everything you're never going
to know
so then when you flip it on I'm I'm in a
real challenge issue that might speak to
your family speak to your friends speak
could speak to random strangers people
are generally open and when when you
talk to something about this don't say
hey mate mate hey mate is all right
you're right you're right but no you
have to seek help be open about it you
know obviously for me that's what I had
to do there was at one Defiant moment
where I had to sort just be honest
really and everyone was like yeah right
cool well you know what can we do and I
was like oh so you're not I'm not gonna
be embarrassed by this rachet now yeah
we've all been there perfect so view
have you ended up building relationships
other mentors and like that then they've
helped you along the way yeah business
owners in recruitment in Australia I've
gone and said to them that you know I'm
going for a transition and the issue
thing you go from being a consultant to
a director and owner right being a
consulting you almost institutionalized
you know what you need to do every day
to get the outcome you looking for right
then you even director on you're like
[ __ ] I haven't done this one before and
people look at you for you know
inspiration motivation and guidance and
you're going what I used to do was get
on the phone and just go and just be you
know show me more how that that side of
it was I can't do that I'm the time to
do that I work on the business Sisu he
certainly did this whole new job after
13 years of recruiting that this is
actually quite a few reached out for
help yeah and so you've got to reach out
to other business owners and MPs and
sort of talk to him about you know how
they never get to the exit or else and
they also this if English as I spoke to
somebody else so that's even at the
consultant level isn't it it's like if
you if you've got aspirations to get
over here and there's Sally in your
office that's got there or there's
someone that you've seen online on
LinkedIn or whatever I'd say yeah like I
love that just actually reached out and
I think I always say this but like I've
experienced this myself and like you'll
be so surprised as to how many people
willing to help yeah I know how many
things have come off the back of the
podcast where people reached out and
like there's so many great things that
happen but that's because people are
actually really willing to help I mean
obviously we talked about earlier with
you before we started about when you did
your first Twitter yeah social side you
know I just got in touch with you you
weren't asking for help but it's so
sometimes it's just nice to give people
exactly up and say hey you're doing a
good thing yeah but people will be
willing
out life you are going for a tough time
in your life [ __ ] no one cares my this
is hard but there will be people will
Intel and ok mate
so then what I'd love to get your
perspective of then is just quickly
actually out of interest because I was
interested to us like when you say like
you build up something then you get the
way you build up something you get the
way what what do you mean by where where
do you need to get it to for you to be
comfortable to give it away as you go I
mean I think you always want to probably
when I look building that construction
team because the construction team is
what now twelve yeah well you sort of
want to know you've got four to six
clients okay you can you can rely on to
bring come in and then it's upon the
consultant to probably go and win for
six more so how did you pass that uncle
you would have built those relationships
and then they use tell them right just
to let you know I'm now gonna probably
do more this you're gonna be speaking to
Tom he's gonna be telling your clients
what you're trying to do as well yeah
get them bought in what you're you know
and we psychometric everyone our
business but I'm very open because I'll
tell our clients what we're trying to
achieve are tell our candidates and yeah
well tell them why I'm getting you know
clients are interested in here because
today that can be a challenge isn't it's
like what was Andrew not calling me do
you know me because I've see yeah you've
got to be open on it because you don't
want people to perceive you like Andrews
too good to talk to us now whatever you
know you've always gotta be accessible
so it's not don't go out to client
meetings it's not like I don't go to
events and see those clients and because
the clients always want to know who's
right at the back you the one making all
decisions at the back of the room they
want to know that person there's not a
Ditka diver yeah so for me when there
are issues that need to be sort of dealt
with I always have to always help with
those issues where relevant and where I
need to sometimes you got a little
people just deal with their own [ __ ] and
say might figure out what you're gonna
do make the mistake you need to make and
then you know what after that don't
worry about it yeah there's ninety nine
percent of the time when people make a
decision to make the right one they're
just scared of making it really yeah
okay that's interesting and okay so then
what would be interested to your
perspective of that and is firstly so
the the team that you've ended up
building mmm how many of those are
original from the UK roughly yeah great
Kelly and Alex a Kelly are state
managers from the UK
Alex where to match that with myself
Adams from the UK and then you got Aaron
who's Ozzy really live in Sydney but the
balance between the team is 50% male
female fish saying outside Ozzy 50% are
really overseas from okay cool
so I guess before I ask you'd like some
of the common things that you've seemed
UK recruits struggle with hmm I think
that'd be really interesting to talk
about like what are the like key key
differences from the UK market been in
recruitment the odds dunno I mean is it
Asian I was to be a real Creole I dunno
I mean what's the war the sort of key
differences yeah I mean obviously I've
touched upon that earlier that's a long
time but I only have experience into two
markets so I work to match it for four
years in Australia yeah the last nine so
when people ask me this some like don't
know because I always dealt with Aussies
and Kiwis but people talk about the UK
being more transactional and Australia
being more relationship pace potentially
that's one thing but I think with
Aussies they're they're more willing to
give out trust but you can lose it
quicker as well really that's one thing
I found is that once you lose trust in
Australia
you're never getting it a lot of grudges
ah they they just do not forget about it
really
um so that's why you know our vision is
all about being the most trusted because
like don't [ __ ] that up yeah okay
because once you've lost that to get it
back is so hard really is it you know
less saturated potentially yes but is it
still a busy market it still prickly
about competition the market yes there
is hmm are there still the highest
performers yeah there are I don't have
enough experience to say because I
probably didn't work in enough agency
yeah by the time but I talk about
Aussies in the way they are that if you
break trust of them you're done you're
literally done you need to move on
they're not gonna they're not gonna get
away with it so I think that's one thing
I found and but their willingness to
sort of meet and have a chat way higher
really yeah way higher because they're
just that way inclined it's a good day
mate how you going that's how you you
don't go alright open conversation sorry
I can't probably offer too much because
you know max check I did relatively well
through my own star on the well yeah but
that probably helps you in that and what
you're just talking about that
direct and open you know no [ __ ] I'm
not trying to but if you were listening
to this and yes if you if you're a
recruit and you're listening to this and
you're in the UK and that let's be let's
be honest if you are probably a bit more
transactional but you're good at what
you do any good and we could have put in
people the right place and you may not
have some sort of relationship and that
may be difficult in because you're
probably more inclined or more easy to
make the mistake or breaking that trust
and that if you go over to the
Australian market I think I thought I've
generally found with the people that
I've worked with in the UK in Australia
that more sales of the other the harder
it is for them to succeed really I'm you
know I was putting some content together
around you don't need to sell she'd tell
the truth just tell me who you are what
you do how you do it and bring ourselves
on is sales but you don't need to
actually do because they already know
what we do or they have a perceived idea
about what we do and then you bring him
into the real picture about what they do
and they go oh [ __ ] that actually sounds
like it's a little bit more crazy how
simple it is just do the right finger
people say in four words what we tell
you recruits like yeah yeah how to get
that fear of loss and all that yeah so I
guess what from your perspective then
what have been like some of the common
challenges that you've seen UK
recruiters have gone over to the AHS
market and trying to be trying to
replicate this success there than UK war
so you probably may be touching it there
but what are some of the common things
you've seen as you've been building your
team assuming that they will be
successful
mmm it'd be one presumption of oh
assuming that they're gonna be the
presumption of I've got four or five
years so I don't have to do what I did
four or five years ago this time when I
go back feeling like am I going there's
no trust no one knows them you know when
you talk about so recruiters you when
they consciously companies they got
their market they've got everything
knocked off but when you're going from a
UK to Australian you know no one why
would you assume you'll have the same
level success by doing by doing half the
work and that's what someone wants told
me is that you go to Australia and you
work 50% harder than you care you'll be
successful bollocks you still gotta
apply the same work ethic yeah but if
you work as hard as you did when you
first started and you've got four years
experience and doing it you you yes it's
having the humility to be like I care
I'm ring have to pull my trap I know
nothing mmm all I know is what I knew in
the UK and every conversation I'm gonna
see what
what I can apply and what I can't was is
that the biggest thing than like a
presumption that they'll be successful
I've done this I've got it boxed off
don't worry about me mate and then they
get there it's like yeah that's nice is
that is that I hear that's a quite
common challenge when like your if
you're hiring sort of experienced
recruiters that they do come with that
sort of and I know I'm doing mate like
relax like let me crack on yeah like you
know I mean is a common challenge we
talk about it a lot in our business
around as we bring people into the
business to start whatever you knew
that's fine but there's a way that we do
things there's a way that our client is
it that's different now
well it looks just the way we are yeah
we all do things differently because
everyone's unique yeah but it's that
willingness to adopt what we do because
I found it many a time where people
you've got her aftercare program our
worker from safety compliance our sort
of system compliance they're people like
I know it's not like this in the UK this
is how it is here so [ __ ] well do it
because we're not a KPI BC don't sit
there and say you know cool targets
accept or else but we set everything
round trust and how we build trust of
our client because that's the one thing
we want to focus on so when we start to
say to people what's your interview -
placement ratio what's your CV interview
they look at me like I've got 14 Ed's
sunlight that's the [ __ ] you need to
know to build trust but because some
come over with the assumption of but
I've done it before can do it again
bollocks I wouldn't come back to UK and
I think that I could be successful I
would go back to day one which is okay
how do i structure my day what habits do
anything I would accept or else okay
interesting I think that that makes a
lot of sense and so I guess what I'd
also like to get you around opinion on
because I think you know you're
well-placed
to show your perception on it is okay as
you've been building this team I'm sure
that you've had some some really good
builders hopefully still have some
really good Billy's and some really good
people what would have been two things
what I was like to ask people about is
what have been the common things that
you've seen and in those people that
have helped them get to that point and
what I always like to ask is so where do
you see people sort of fallen short or
the habits that they have that and
prevent them from breaking through that
ceiling do you know I mean yeah well
there's all the the sort of common
things that you see in the high
performer
in your business well yeah I think
Philip we probably it's smart in the
fact that we've profiled every single
person through a psychrometric yeah
what's that just quickly like what's the
foot presence behind that um because you
what you you know you think you know
people yeah but sometimes you don't but
that you start with you right so I'm
aware of my strengths but I'm also
acutely aware of my weaknesses so that's
something that's made me so powerful
when and self-awareness what but not
everyone is so the first fuse is right
let's pray for every hyper form we've
got and there's a common theme that came
out so now openness mmm urgency energy
elimination so these were things that
people they probably say that again open
openness openness to change and advice
yeah accommodation which was they
generally they won't accommodate certain
things once the standard said that's it
yeah they won't accommodate anything
else urgency yeah having higher having
high energy yeah and the other thing we
always empathy yeah so what we what we
then decided from that was the two
things we've got permission to play we
call it which is will hire someone that
they can show two things which is
driving care only driven everyday to
succeed any things you look for when
you're higher and you care you generally
give a [ __ ] about your clients canidates
and colleague Sonya yes you want to do
really well yes you're gonna bring loads
of energy and urgency but you're never
gonna throw somebody under the bus
they're never gonna Brett and the
accommodation part comes from you're
never gonna allow this standards to slip
and those are the five key things we can
profile anyone on and we've seen of our
highest performers they all sit in the
same on there's like this wave that
comes through in its own right okay well
you know what we know that everyone's
gonna be the same but those are those
five things that we look for yeah is it
anything else within that than within
these high performers that you say no
those five things to me are always
though you know the urgency of urgency
of action they come in every day they've
got high energy they won't allow
substandard sort of work in time etc
else but they've got a lot of empathy
and they're open to feedback so that's
why we came back of our values of honest
communication feedback care and focus
they all fair and suit you know I've
just heard you say that on the phone did
you consider or have you considered this
mmm you select a business leader whose
billion six seven hundred grand a year
they're cool with that because you know
what it's helping them improve yeah and
that's how they how did he how do these
people with these traits deal with the
[ __ ] times
I think the same as every what was
freaked about earlier just talking about
it haven't perspective perspective as
well once you've been in recruitment
maybe three five seven nine years and we
probably all need a recession by the way
I know that word should be used at the
moment but I've been through one and and
we got through it you know what there's
gonna be good days and there's gonna be
bad days and we actually live in a world
it's a set of rejection where Ivan being
rejected by clients
we're either rejecting candidates all
clients so we're always most time be
said no so you can celebrate the good
times along with it but perspectives a
wonderful thing you sort of go well
where was her three months ago where am
i today where could I go perspective
huge yeah when you really tap into that
understand yeah that's what I say to
every new consultant is think about
where you were we and where you are
today yeah we give me a week's time and
then fast for two years so easy to [ __ ]
I'm gonna be ruthless in these yeah okay
and then the other parts that there may
I think that's really cool that you
profile people and it's amazing that all
so they've got their similar drivers in
it so I guess and then what would you
see in the people that you'll just like
if they liked you know I mean that I
just sort of just struggling to break
that you know I'm now getting a lot of
messages where people like he's sure I'm
hitting 150 180 km I can't break that
200 250 more whatever to go I mean like
what how war the common things or habits
or whatever that you're seeing in people
that struggling to break through to that
next that next edge I think you've
always got to be looking at your 8020
rule which is that you know people buy a
business for 20 clients but you also
need to be turned over 20% your clients
quarter-on-quarter
you've always been bringing new
businesses are can never settle on what
you've got we talked about it earlier
and that the assumption of I've got
these covers I get complacent
yeah but you've got to be continuing to
have those conversations with your
clients and you know one of our
consultants has gone from being a
high-performance appealing and coulda be
high performer because we went to their
offices a client they went yeah so we've
recruited their forty people last year
twenty were viral X and twenty one
another agency and his face just dropped
because he was like what hold on a
minute
yeah and so I was like there's your
assumption because he'd never asked a
question about hi he just assumed you
didn't like amazing yeah an assumption
is the mother of all fuck-ups yeah right
Steve said their money train you know it
was evil but
you know and so when you get to a
hunting you K you know what's that
probably 30 placements yeah but you've
got 52 weeks in a year why can't you
make one place with the we can
realistically any gray a so break it
down so it doesn't sound as huge I mean
like actually by number do by placements
think it's about to him by the number of
placements you're making to the market
you're in because your average fee will
take care of itself if you're making
sure you protecting your terms but if
you're made doesn't sound as much any of
it as that now if you're making 24
placements in a year honestly you could
double that mmm by working with better
clients better can that it some folks in
better roles okay so you mentioned I
know I know I've already sort of a sure
about it but I guess what because like
how much of a struggle for your guys in
office as it like business development
is that fair to say like that's quite a
big challenge for a lot of people right
yeah it is for a lot of people that was
for me you know though first phone calls
but how did you help people with that
because I think I love it as I said
people always ask me about that long and
you just said there that 20% make sure
that you always bring the new clients
and that's kind of our business things
and I think one like think about when
either their I definitely got more way
more confident with it but I can see
their it'd be very easy to be like I've
got all these clients that like want to
give me time these things the thought of
them being rejected more and happened to
do that as a bit like that that that's
that complacency part but is complacency
it's also Drive you know how driven are
you and how what's you really what you
really want to put yourself out there
and be you know people talk about the
night be sitting there 99% 99.9% 9.8%
where do you really want do you really
want to be highly successful because if
you do you'll do it if you don't you'll
sit where you are going back to nips or
new business development except you're
out some you have to do it every day you
can't sit there and think my clients are
gonna get me through the next five years
because they're not there their
conditions will change they'll bring a
new hire managers new line managers so
you can never assume that you've got it
because you haven't when you go to new
consultants of new BD etc it's going
back and saying you know this K first
phone call is gonna be the worst one
you're never gonna make it's be real cuz
it's gonna be horrible and a horrible
they gave me the worst person I could
have my firm I work speak beauty call
was my first call because they knew who
I gave me the phone said this is the
person we want you to call any litt
[ __ ] rip and the bloke said to me that
be the worst when you ever get
I mean then it has been yes obviously we
don't do that to people there but we can
hire them again we've all been there you
know it's not like anyone's walked in
and here's all your clients
we've got to get on that phone and
introduce ourselves and sell and we're
like oh my days yeah hey it's a good
date Andrew from designing but how you
go in there like you hear that Huff and
you're like right oh this is gonna be
this is gonna be difficult
and then Elvis don't take too much your
time and touch base it's like you say
[ __ ] words just try and be real and
try and be different but just know you
know what you can [ __ ] it up more than
you're gonna get it right in the first
probably three to six months
hmm and but after time and after you be
speaking to these people every
conversation gets easier because I get
phone calls from Rex Rex now making new
ones and they sound terrible in the fun
for everyone but I said well I say teams
look nothing right now give me a call
for weeks and this is what most clients
would do to you don't I'm not interested
give me a call and for the eight weeks
or don't call me so okay I'll give you a
call and four weeks and check in because
I know you're busy
email them tell them you're calling the
four weeks called them in four weeks
yeah for a while I we spoke four weeks
ago you were too busy to talk at the
time except where else
great done after I suppose some people
just get afraid of cold call and BD I'm
like but every time you deliver you
building trust and who said that that
really helped and that that really
helped me actually when I'm really with
yeah this is exactly right okay cool
I'll touch base of your call you in for
six weeks on the Bukit my knowing now
I'm booking a diary yeah follow up
follow up that is that helps a lot than
as well it used to be seven to nine
touch points before you got a bomb
now it's twelve to fourteen because
we're so busy but my wife works
internally but I've got friends who work
internally
they've got PSAs and people called them
now and again and say hey I'm you know
looking forward to getting the PSA and
they go we'll give us a call em ups time
and we'll catch up or give us a call in
three months
they don't call back hmm you're done
you've already failed where if someone
says because if you call back and say
always spoke before that's again you're
you're elevating they were selves you
are nothing right now
okay I'll call you in four weeks in the
meantime it was it hard to feel role and
then you call back for weeks and they
said no there's nothing there but the
how we broke into some of our clients of
construction we spoke to him every four
weeks and when their job was advertised
I don't
get in touch and say I'm just gonna ask
the question because you know I'm keen
to work with you
then each opportunity to work on this
role know Andrews not right now don't
take offense to it it's just that they
said at least they would apply yeah but
then eventually I pick up the phone and
you've got the best company in Australia
calling you about free rolls they're
gonna whack you doing that's when you
like win sometimes it takes two four
years but if you want to be in
recruitment that's how long it's a long
game innit yeah how I'm just quit oh and
I want to ask you some things around and
branding the stuff because I think
obviously as a business I think from
what I can see you've been on an
interesting journey hmm I think you
you've definitely got an a personal
brand but just quickly
how does mindset fit into all this is
that do not I mean because I think that
you're probably the first person that
sat down with it have said openly that
you've what what was the word that you
use when you've profiled everyone hmm so
again yes like a metric sorry so like
where does mindset fit into all this in
your opinion because the mindset comes
from Drive yeah right so you comes from
someone being driven to succeed but it
also comes with habits you've got to do
the same thing time and time again yeah
to get impact so when people start doing
sort of social media presence they do it
once in a but you check that on LinkedIn
this site that's nice what do you need a
next one oh when I mmm the mindset is I
want to build a brand yeah but before
you do that what brands you want to
build its habits the mindset thing
comforts are habits which is I'm gonna
make sure I do the same things every day
because by doing them every day I know
eventually get an outcome from it and
I'm not gonna give up because it doesn't
work after a week or a month you know
you've got a continued cover than people
cuz you know in today's world it's lying
put something out you want like
something straight away you're on
comments yeah like you know I mean it's
the whole sort of innocent gratification
thing so how did you cultivate that in
your people it's some allowance on send
that the the impressions I think likes
and comments are one thing there's
people always watch in the background
right it's always talk to people that
the number of people who interact with
our brand in a year so last year our
brand was interacted with our
impressions
113 million times yeah I was like that's
9 times the population I remember they
are people that's not last lot a number
yeah but they are people at all times
the population of Australia
almost 5
in fact saris madness and you all you're
saying to people is that you're building
a way innocent presence so when you do
pick up the phone yeah now and again the
below you have seen you comment that's
what it's all about you're combining the
both yeah but then how do you bet then
definitely but then what about just in
terms of like your people recruitment
the brand piece like how'd you cultivate
that because you gotta have a long-term
mindset yeah and that is what people
really struggle with yeah they can't see
they're likely under 10 or they can't
see above the rejection daily in like
you know 5k months or whatever do not I
mean so how do you cultivate that people
in the journey you know you talk about
your own my own personal journey about
Kelly's journey Alex's journey we all
started as recruitment consultants
you've got a ping people it because
we've all been there yeah and we are
where we are today because some of us
built these habits and we do it
consistently in every day but it's
different for every vehicle we're all
unique my personal branding came about
through authenticity you know being true
and being open and being honest so when
I talk about things and LinkedIn or
Facebook whatever else not really
selling I'm just telling my own stories
being honest but that's what it's about
let's trust for us how and so yeah when
I look at your yeah because you've
really done well that I guess how has it
helped you do not mean give me purpose
really yeah so when things are [ __ ] you
know cuz one of the things that I got
taught was like when things are really
[ __ ] look at what you're doing because
that's all you can look at right you
can't look at what they have a company
are doing what the markets do you're
gonna look what you're doing so when you
start building your own brand rather not
be externally or internally just look at
what you're doing every day and have it
having that purpose so whenever I sound
now sort of meet consultants meet
clients meet candidates because I talk a
lot about trust and authenticity when
they meet they're like [ __ ] he's really
honest but that means I'm being true to
myself and I think in life unless you've
been if you're not being true to
yourself you're playing up at the play
in an act there's no point in a plane
and that there's no sustainable no it's
not you can't just exist you can't play
an app because eventually you'll burn
out and all you'll be found out and the
worst thing is that you found out yeah
100% I think that I think for me that is
the great thing about the online piece
is line if you are a [ __ ] recruiter the
like you can be exposed like that and
that that's a great thing is like you
couldn't sort of brand that you have and
how people perceive you like you
couldn't
that and it not be true because you're
just one comment away of someone so and
roommate you you're lying
hmm and everyone can see that yes you
know I mean that's what I spoke about on
LinkedIn Vanessa perception and is one
thing but how you treat people the row
of life that leaves an everlasting
impression yeah you know they're two
different things perception is someone
built up a perception of you and then
they get in touch and then you do what
you do and if you don't deliver or you
don't be the person that you you knew
the or met it's perceived as she does
that you're done because that's that's
the whole game with that and I think
seeing your sort of presence online and
stuff like that I think it's very much
in line with what you are perceiving
that which is which is should be the
objective everyone is like when I do sit
down that caning and client and they're
like wow I'm drew you exactly how I
thought you was yeah yeah that's like so
powerful and really valuable but I guess
the question that I always get and I
have my own way of answering it is like
because I'm sure you get this is like I
can do but how does it make me more
money
mmm has it made you more money yes maybe
more trusted so people have come to us
and engage with us clients candidates
and consultants because we do what we
say we're gonna do so eventually
obviously other people want that
experience success or else so has it
made me more money well I was 23 when I
got into recruitment I didn't have a
degree I was working in the tax office
as a tax inspector I'm 36 and I've got a
business or two in Australia and I
didn't do it by being a dick it I did
being honest and being you know I expose
myself at times except or else as
vulnerable you know what that's fine
yeah because the good people will grab
hold of that and make make you better
the [ __ ] ones they'll take advantage of
it don't worry about it yeah it's sort
of you know there's a book given taped
by Adam grant it talks a lot about
giving yeah just give just be you and
starts with just being you so when
people say to me has it made me more
money well I don't know because I don't
know what the other parts would have led
to but I'm pretty happy well you know
how his recruiting is like wallet I can
pick up the phone and I know how that's
gonna go or default of obviously putting
someone online and their hand done
before you don't know you don't know how
it's gonna go when you pick up the phone
or post online just do it right Nike say
everyday it's because it's still this
logo or logo slogan sorry but just
and don't worry about the outcome it's
gonna cause accept as long as it's
authentic as long as it's true in your
being honest if you're doing something
to gain
straight away eventually you'll be found
out you'll be a taker yeah I mean again
you just give out just give give give
and then the other givers will give out
as well that's that's so true how I've
approached it as well but I just know
it's hard to tap into that it's hard
well you got you're not facts as well
I'll give you a big [ __ ] on you some of
your posts just been honest yeah and the
thing people need to not be afraid of is
that you know people you know you read a
message from someone or someone comments
on your on your article I mean I did one
article it got like [ __ ] half million
but a million likes and fifty million
views it was like crazy was about always
leaving the office on time so I did it
about three four years ago didn't expect
to do it did and it was the most light
at one point ever and I was like oh my
days and so many people commenting but
at the time I was receiving him already
negatively that you want your
disagreement me you're attacking me
they're not they're just offering their
point of view and that's what can get ya
and you do the first you hairs on your
back and run you like a brick but the
thing is because it's coming from a
person not every wasn't like you know
that's just part of it 50% of the world
ain't gonna like you you said are people
just we're not all the same we have
different views it's why in politics we
get the right and the left yeah we've
all got a compass so I guess do it just
just have ran that off then with your
whole journey with it and stuff like
what's your sort of go-to advice for
recruiters that listen obviously I was
good mind advice and that's sort of the
business I'm building now but what's
your advice went from your own
perspective been implemented it's always
hard to summarize but I think just just
be honest about who you are you want to
go to work every day make an impact and
if you don't want to go to work every
day if you don't want to make an impact
and don't do what you're doing in short
be honest about who you are and what you
stand for
and convey that online yeah and and
every part of your life not just online
and every part of your life just be who
you are and be honest about who you are
and you know online in an office in a
pub whatever else so that's my advice to
anyone in any walk of life
it's just be you and be honest about who
you are and what you stand for where
your weaknesses are way
shrimps are yeah be proud of your shrimp
just be aware of your weaknesses but
always working your shrimps because
that's what will get you for it yeah
that'll get you through as long as
you're where your weakness is at the
same time yeah good advice man cool so
look I guess what I always like to ask
people before we finish me yeah I want
quick than that yesterday so what what
are you excited about them what's going
on in your world for me I'm excited
about the diversification the business
we launched our public sector business
back in back in March but when we also
did that we've reset our vision and a
vision now is to be the most trusted
recruiting agency in Australia and I'm
so proud of that vision because I talked
to the consult other people receive that
the first thing they say is how do you
build trust what do you mean and I talk
to people around you know you can try
and say you're the biggest you could try
and say you're the leader
but can you quantify it but you quantify
trust by the metrics we talked about
earlier about you know CV to interview
placement ratios etc but for me I read a
great book how to achieve extraordinary
results by focusing the one thing and
that's what I always talk about in life
is focus what's the one thing if you get
that right everything else for as a
result it's trust because people want to
trust people but in the treatment trust
anyone at the start but so that's what
we talked about how is our vision being
the most trusted and then what system is
now talked about we don't promote people
about how much they bill is but how much
trust they build some really really
start seeing this journey where our
consultants yes obviously there's a
financial outcome but interested that
the result happens as a result of
building trust so focus on that focus on
keeping your metrics low keeping your
feedback scores high your placement rate
low you know what you'll make money you
will make money whereas if you focus on
just billing you'll make money but you
might not build the best client around
it so that's been absolutely love that
and as I'm now working with businesses
and individuals one of the things I do
is I get in to think about what they
want to be known for and they're marking
one of the most literally every
recruiter said it so far I don't want to
be perceived as just another recruiter
nothing that and then and then when
we're talking about what you do want to
be be seen as it does
that's what you're talking about there
trust these things so I'm really excited
to see how this all levels out because I
think there's there'll be a lot of
people listen and Russia's wanker nation
on the ballot I mean what you want to
say to people is what we define as
success because what you'll find is some
people will talk about the money that
they bill the money that they earn the
issue then you go to ask them is okay
what about the trust what about when
things go tight with your clients or you
candidates in are they going to come
back to you when when they're not
looking for people as much as yeah and
what I found was that the most trusted
recruiters in my career the clients have
always looked after them the good times
and the bad times the ones that just
took the piss and we're just about the
money they're either not in recruitment
anymore they've had about five jobs in
that time yeah so the wank Enis it might
come across as that but actually if you
think about it it all makes sense which
is if you've got low metrics logo
placement rates high retention rate high
business rate you're gonna make money
yeah absolutely and the trustor vision I
love that that's amazing what and what
else is going on the new brand any
business there that's obviously a big
thing for us as well I'm a meters moving
more into the rower
I became managing director the business
back in July I'm to learning about being
an MD and not a recruitment consultant
every day is always a challenge because
I have high urgent's you have i energy
but i'd have low abstract reasoning so
that's gonna really think about things
sometimes so this stuff comes naturally
mean you listen to the cows come home
here but when someone says why it took
about strategy and planning an execution
I'm not so learn about me and my
attempts at witnesses that that's
another exciting thing as well and don't
get me wrong going through another doubt
they're going for a cycle in the market
seem you know who flourishes who doesn't
you know seen Kelly moving to estate
manager role you know trying to you know
rebuild a Melvyn be since they're all
exciting things don't get me wrong I'm
also [ __ ] myself at the same time
yeah but he'll come from they come good
in the end
we commit well a question I always ask
people to finish off is and if you could
communicate it to and every single
recruiter out there that would take
Andrews advice hmm
listen it could be a phrase a sentence
one words oh god mine one one phrase one
word it could be anything it could be
anything it doesn't have to be one word
it couldn't be anything that comes -
they'd implement your advice to take it
on what would you say to these people if
they're listening I think you know be
open to feedback
and be driven to succeed when I think
about how I've got to where I've got to
where we've got where we got to because
we listened to people around us but we
came in every day like I said earlier
with that drive yeah you know want to
make an impact every day because that's
what it's all about you know you could
have the worst day of your life but you
at the end of the day you get a good
candidate good client job one and it all
changes suggesting focus on making an
impact every day whether it's big or
small and that will carry you through
the bad times as well as a good times
and human pleasure in absolute